[Laughter]  dude you're getting confident I love it  I love this version because you know you  got some awards some acknowledgments  from your show you have another show  that you're doing a pilot for another  show  right and I feel like you there's a  confidence about you that I don't like  your Energy's [ __ ] up and they're back  we're starting over we want the old  brick I want the old we want the older  Rick I would like to acknowledge one  thing and they're going to start over  yeah I'm not that surprised that  somebody feeling positive and confident  makes you uncomfortable let's start on  over oh oh wow yeah yeah  I hope he doesn't cut your back up